[Música]
hablamos de lo ocurrido en el fútbol
mexicano luego de que un enfrentamiento
entre hinchas en el estadio la
corregidora de la ciudad de querétaro
durante el partido que le traba las puso
en evidencia a un problema de fondo en
este deporte en ese país la violencia
terminó con un saldo de al menos 26
personas heridas según la fiscalía de
ese estado cifra que es muy contrastante
con las extraoficiales que también
manejan medios de comunicación que
aseguran que son al menos 17 personas
fallecidas estos hechos son confusos y
andan en generado todo tipo de
reacciones en rechazo a la violencia en
el fútbol mexicano algo que
lamentablemente no es nada nuevo
entre las principales reacciones está la
del presidente de la liga mexicana de
fútbol mikel arriola que anunció que
quienes estén en los partidos de
campeonato ya no se permitirá la entrada
a los estadios de las barras de los
equipos visitantes además la fifa que a
través de un comunicado se declaró
consternada por todo este trágico
incidente y pidió a las autoridades
locales a hacer justicia rápidamente
saludamos entonces a nuestro segundo
invitado él es hugo sánchez y niño
periodista e investigador de la
universidad autonoma de mexico unam
además tiene más de 2 décadas estudiando
las barras del fútbol nacional en mexico
gracias por atender nuestra invitación
hubo en directo américa de france 24
lamentablemente en un hecho como esto
que una ama una de las cosas que llama
la atención de este ataque es que
oficialmente sólo se habla de heridos
cuando hay varios vídeos circulando en
las redes sociales y también medios de
comunicación locales usted debe saber lo
más que muestran cuerpos inmóviles en
todo este estadio que se sabe del estado
de salud de esos lesionados hay algún
reporte que reconozca que si hubo
víctimas mortales en todo esto hubo un
bueno aquí estés
estos hechos violentos del fin de semana
conmocionado la opinión pública que en
méxico y haya informaciones cruzadas
diversas por un lado la las fuentes
oficiales indican que no hay muertos y
hay solamente de personas heridas
hospitalizados pero pues en las redes
sociales de méxico prácticamente hay una
gran cantidad de testimonios y
evidencias que probablemente sea
víctimas mortales de esto todavía no hay
digamos una parte oficial al respecto
pero bueno hay mucha información que da
cuenta de ello y compañeros
probablemente las víctimas son los que
se han encargado de difundir esto en las
redes sociales
también hubo hay muchas denuncias en
torno a las falencias de seguridad que
había en el estadio de que hubo mejor
dicho en el estadio de querétaro durante
todo ese día el partido en su opinión
cuáles fueron porque se terminó
desatando esta batalla campal que vimos
que además se trasladó al campo de juego
los jugadores tuvieron que que
esconderse y resguardarse en los
vestidores para no ser agredidos pues
todo un escenario bien lo que ocurrió sí
bueno los protocolos de seguridad de los
estadios aquí en méxico pues se supone
que plantean este tipo de hechos y se
supone que me estrategia para de alguna
manera neutralizar lo dicho protocolo
creo que no pero en el estadio de
querétaro la corregidora sin embargo
bueno hay algunos indicadores previos
tal vez 15 días antes de que estos
hechos ocurrieran que anticipaban que
esto podría
explotar estos indicadores bueno el
primero es el grito homofóbico en méxico
ha cobrado digamos fama internacional
que es un grito que cantan lo que al que
hacen alusión los aficionados mexicanos
que tiene una connotación violenta y
sexista un segundo indicador pues es que
hay grupos de barristas mexicanos que
utilizan mantas o lo que se dice aquí
significó cómo narcomantas que son
mantas que utilizan los grupos
delictivos
para inscribir en ellas mensajes de
amenazas contra directivos contra
jugadores contra los propios
directores técnicos cuando su equipo no
marcha bien en el ámbito futbolístico el
cuarto indica el tercer indicador que es
que hay algunos jugadores y de aquí en
méxico profesionales que mantienen
alguna comunicación vía redes sociales
con algunos capos del narco y finalmente
pues un grupo de animación de estas
barras que allí en méxico recientemente
en una gilera en simbólicamente pusieron
las cabezas de algunos jugadores del
cuerpo técnico y de directivos porque no
les gusta como con el equipo y desean
con este mensaje a ven danzar los
entonces estos elementos en previos ya
anticipaban que llegue un ambiente
violento en méxico y que en cualquier
momento podía estallar y bueno
finalmente este fin de semana ocurrió
hugo hablemos entonces de toda esta
problemática trasladado al mundial que
vamos a ver en 2026 dónde méxico es una
de estas sedes organizadoras de la copa
del mundo después de lo que vimos y
después de todo este contexto de
seguridad que estamos viendo en mexico
como usted bien lo detalló peligra que
se haga el mundial en mexico en 2026 y
yo creo que uno de los impactos este de
estos hechos del fin de semana es
justamente eso que allá que este mundial
del 26 pueda venirse abajo obviamente
las autoridades mexicanas tanto del
fútbol como gubernamentales están
buscando la manera de justificar lo que
ocurrido y bueno de encontrar algunos de
los culpables también bueno como uno de
los efectos inmediatos
de estos hechos pues es que esta semana
aquí en méxico se define ya en los
partidos finales de méxico en la
eliminatoria para catar y bueno pues con
las sanciones que méxico tiene por el
grito rico pues es otro factor también
de riesgo y finalmente la federación de
fútbol mexicana pues estaba muy ocupada
en establecer convenios de colaboración
con la liga norteamericana con la m ls
que es una liga muy rica económicamente
hablando y bueno pues lo que está en
riesgo además del mundial son una serie
de proyectos deportivos y económicos
pues de esta gráficos del fútbol en
méxico hubo muy rápidamente yo nos queda
un minuto para finalizar nuestra
conversación usted que ha estudiado las
'barras bravas' hemos visto hechos como
estos lamentables en el pasado si en el
pasado habiendo hecho desde inicios de
este siglo en 2004 en 2010 2011
2017 19 desafortunadamente sólo cuando
corren de ellos las autoridades voltean
a ver el problema y tratan de encontrar
una solución coyuntural se requieren
soluciones de largo plazo y
diagnósticos más serios que vean cuáles
son fortalezas y debilidades de estos
grupos de animación
no solo en méxico sino en toda américa
latina tiene una presencia ambiental en
el fútbol